клони самого себе сам і тисячі потрібно
Мартін Ван Хіл у роті за місяць до
парламентських виборів у нідерландах
конкуренцію селянського будинку крота
листопаді у бюлетенях 31 партія хочемо
кримінально за вантаж право популісти партія
свободи герта вілдерса вбиці вивезення the
netherlands з'їзд а закрита кордони
батьківщини буду радий і фікова ну і угоду про
асоціацію з Україною
її голосування нідерландський парламент
ви вирішивши провести вже після вибору
martijn van harvard зістригаючи після
зручних і вправо тата листя і are one
кілометрів from begin with нас один
кілометр добили і 5 кілометрів до них
джон і я хочу ми закриємо і кордони
видного моя рада євро немає ургу від МСБ
ллю негайно це у серію європу та цап
дивуватися компанія закриється компанії
ебботта людей аки тут протягнути яким
подібну c убити on keep on a віллдерса в
витрачати роботу почав герт вілдерс roser
у цих карт ще популісти менших країв
залягу та ісламським радикалізмом їм
sequel кисть мігранти в парових трохи
курені населення нідерландів то вбити
я економічний протекціонізм чи чисельним
вирубних грудок і віват лідер партії
свобода замість самого парламенту та
лімбург osb одягається на вірний не до
старий чисел нідерландського гульдена
контролю на кордонах чи нідерланди позою
з халфу 100 разів для pudge звідки льону
беніки будуть з новими з метою поляк
edge та руни cpc означає більше робочих
місць
замша боку в їх відомі означає і
крім торгувати менше мікро і нами
це дуже легко у клас ти двосторонню
торгівлю воду на приклад зніме шина
наскільки та c легко покажи брексит їм
годинник на довгий двір і нічийним і поруч
та d та builders ознайомити набу валу
петрін cursus пертви
особливі ви разом у нло на кордоні змі
матчі але для народів вся правий популіст
застанем і досвід його не і ми тут за нього
готові проголосувати та 32 сотки вибір
тип у team їй волосся і про ти
адже ми за галина Петро і повз принципи
усієї людини на мехматі мгу Німеччини
на кшталт з я не хочу а не думати про не
говорить а про нього
партія свободи травня шанси після ст
porsche місці на парламентських виборах у
бар з ним путінці воно означає шоу верки
builders обов'язково вчена шкода країни
від тварин black їх партійних по-батькові
revo ти знімку а лиття